[Music]
medical self-help is an emergency
measure to be used only in cases of
sudden or extraordinary misfortune
if people require medical care in the
course of normal everyday living they
should always be treated by a doctor
however when disaster strikes you may
not be able to obtain trained medical
aid in
time there are many forms of disaster
they can happen to you and your family
at any moment
this film is one of a series on medical
self-help
its purpose is to teach you what to do
in an emergency situation when there is
no doctor
this powerful x-ray machine a tool of
medical science is being used for
healing purposes
the radiant energy it emits is able to
kill all living tissue within its being
both sick and healthy cells of the human
body
its invisible rays so highly penetrative
that protective shielding with lead
glass windows must be used
x-rays are much like the gamma rays of
radioactive fallout
we began our picture with x-rays because
you are all to some degree familiar with
their effects
but radioactive fallout is another
matter
if you're like most people it creates
many questions in your mind and you have
doubtless read or heard some falsehoods
and misconceptions
this film will tell you what you need to
know about fallout
so that if our country is ever subjected
to a nuclear attack
you can help yourself and your family to
survive its dangers
for fallout is probably the most
dangerous product of nuclear disaster in
terms of the number of people who could
be affected
it is also the one from which we are
best able to protect ourselves
let's examine what happens when a
nuclear weapon is exploded near the
earth
first there is blast or the pressure
wave created by the explosion
along with heat the most intense ever
created on earth
both will extend great distances from
the point of the explosion from 1 to 20
or 25 miles depending on the size of the
weapon
however the further away you are from
the site of the explosion the less are
the chances you will suffer the fatal
effects of blast and heat
there is yet a third immediate result of
a nuclear detonation
initial radiation
the final effect is residual radiation
the main concern of this film
or radiation that follows the explosion
and one that may remain at high
altitudes for some time before falling
back to earth
what exactly is residual radiation
our sun like other stellar bodies of the
universe is a giant nuclear furnace
burning at temperatures of millions of
degrees
while emitting various types of
radiation
among these are gamma rays
shorter in wavelength than their closest
neighbor x-rays
the earth's atmosphere prevents these
radiations
dangerous to the health of man and
animal from reaching our planet
however when a nuclear weapon is
exploded
man is creating on earth in the
splitting of atomic nuclei
his own nuclear furnace to produce the
gamma and beta radiations of outer space
let's see now just how this radiation is
created
at the time of the burst vast amounts of
dirt stone and other debris vaporized by
the heat of the explosion are sucked up
into the rising clouds
as the mushroom cloud forms these
particles are made radioactive
for as they cool and condense they are
contaminated by residue from the bomb
these particles when they fall back to
earth are what we call radioactive
fallout
can you or anyone else predict with
accuracy the pattern by which fallout
particles will return to earth
the answer is no
for fallout will depend on the number
size and location of nuclear weapons
exploded
and the direction of upper air currents
let's for example explore the fallout
produced by one of these nuclear weapons
it sends its column of radioactive
material up to 80 000 feet or about 16
miles or more above the earth
here the radioactive particles beginning
to drift downward are at the mercy of
upper air currents that vary from day to
day
descending at various altitudes through
many different layers of air that may be
moving at varying speeds and directions
thus winds on the surface of the earth
give little help in determining the
direction or the occurrence of fallout
meteorologists with their special
instruments however can appraise
altitudes as well as the total distance
fallout will be carried
in a nuclear attack keep tuned to your
local radio station it will keep you
posted where fallout is taking place and
its approximate amount
though you may be able to see this dust
once it reaches the earth you cannot see
or detect the radiation it emits without
the aid of radiological instruments
nor can you taste smell or feel this
radiation
why is fallout so dangerous to human and
animal life
because each particle gives off
radiation as if it were a tiny x-ray
machine
this radiation consists mainly of gamma
rays which are extremely penetrating
like x-rays
gamma rays are able to injure even
destroy the cells of our body if we are
exposed to a sufficient dosage long
enough
or if we eat or drink material
contaminated by fallout
particles
exposure to gamma rays can make you sick
can even cause death
however no matter how long one may be
exposed to fallout he does not become
radioactive
nor can anyone catch radiation sickness
from him like a contagious disease
in fact
this radiation cannot make anyone or
anything
radioactive
now let us suppose that fallout has
descended on this can
we'll let salt represent fallout dust
the particles don't go through the tin
the radiation does but radiation is
harmless to all except living materials
it has no effect on the food inside
now if you wipe away the fallout
particles or better still wash them away
the food inside cannot be contaminated
and is perfectly safe to eat
the same is true of all foods and
liquids that have been protected by
packagings or containers
even the thinnest layer of cellophane
if you don't swallow the dust there is
no ill effect
if water for washing is in short supply
canned goods that may have been exposed
to fallout can be handled safely with a
piece of paper towel
use one sheet of paper to lift the can
and turn it upside down there is no dust
on the bottom
now dispose of the paper
wipe the sides of the can with a new
piece of towel
and don't forget to put the contaminated
paper in a covered receptacle
now open the clean top
there will be no harmful particles in
the food itself
a sealed loaf of bread that has been
exposed to fallout can be salvaged in a
similar manner
turn the loaf upside down to expose the
bottom which will be clear of dust
then dispose of the towel
now insert a sharp knife through the wax
paper at the center of the loaf and cut
upwards
making a slot four or five inches
lengthwise
insert your fingers through the slot and
rip the paper slowly open
the bread can be safely removed to a
clean plate
finally dispose of the wax paper
contaminated vegetables such as potatoes
can be paired like this
use a clean piece of newspaper and
working first in one corner cut off one
end
move to a clean surface of the paper and
peel in this manner
move to another area of the paper and
remove the other end
dispose of all peelings and soiled paper
carefully
after handling any contaminated food
containers or vegetables wash your hands
fallout dust is dangerous but it can be
dealt with by following safe procedures
there is another widespread legend
the fear that fallout spells death to
all life on earth
the plain fact is that even if a great
number of nuclear weapons were exploded
the resulting fallout would cover only a
small area of the world's total land
mass
the real concern then is this
if we are in that area
how do we protect ourselves
like x-rays radiation from fallout can
go through almost every kind of building
material
over 99 percent would pass through glass
66 percent through wood sheathing
50
through a brick veneer wall
but only one percent of gamma radiation
would penetrate 18 inches of concrete
and though it's not a building material
it's important to know that only one
percent would pass through 25 inches of
earth
quite aside from the shielding effect of
building materials
the intensity of radiation decreases
with the square of the distance from the
source
thus
ten feet away from a particle of fallout
the radiation rate is only one percent
of that encountered at a distance of one
foot
other things being equal the central
parts of a building are safer
the radiation rate or the intensity from
fallout decreases with the passage of
time
in fact
for every sevenfold increase in time
the radiation will be reduced by a
factor of ten
that means that at seven hours after the
explosion
the radiation level will be about 10
of its intensity at one hour
at 49 hours it will be about one percent
within two weeks the radiation rate can
be expected to decay to about one tenth
of one percent
therefore the most vital period to seek
protection from fallout is the first few
days after nuclear attacks
even more so the first few hours
but remember
even with the passage of time
a low level of radiation can be
dangerous
that is why you may need to remain
within a sheltered area for as long as
two weeks
these then are the three basic factors
in protection against fallout
time
distance
and shielding
time meaning the longer you stay
protected from fallout the safer you
will be
distance or the further away you get
from fallout the safer you will be
shielding meaning the more mass or
weight you put between yourself and
fallout
the safer you will be
you have often seen this sign on
buildings it means that indoors is a
public fallout shelter
one of many and various kinds of
buildings in your community that are
similarly identified
architects and engineers have carefully
surveyed the shielding qualities of
these areas to ensure they offer a
minimum protection factor of 40 or more
meaning that
in the event of fallout from a nuclear
explosion the mass and weight this
shelter will place between you and the
source of radiation
will make you at least 40 times safer
than if you were outdoors
each of these shelters will hold at
least 50 people
and has been stocked by the government
with austere supplies
food
water
sanitation
equipment medical kits
and radiological instruments
but what about millions who live in
suburbs or rural areas often far beyond
quick walking distance of the nearest
public shelter
with foresight you can have a home
shelter for the protection of your
family
built from specifications and cost
estimates for various types of shelters
provided by your local civil defense
office
the home shelter should be stocked with
supplies of food and water sufficient
for two weeks
here you are afforded time
distance and shielding if and when
fallout so dangerous to human health
should ever occur in your community
just how much radiation can you receive
without becoming sick
we measure exposure to gamma radiation
from fallout in units called wrenching
they're the same units used to measure
x-rays
named for vilheim conrad wrenching the
discoverer of x-rays
people and animals may develop radiation
sickness if they have been exposed to
large amounts of radiation over a short
period of time
few people become sick who have been
exposed to a total radiation dose of 100
wrenches or less
however
exposure to more than 300 wrenches over
a period of a few days will cause
sickness
may cause death
and if you receive an exposure of 600
renkins in that same period of time
death is almost certain
how can you tell just how much radiation
you've been exposed to
these are the instruments commonly used
to detect and measure radiation
they are part of the equipment supplied
to the radiological monitoring team of
every public shelter
with them you can determine not only the
total amounts of radiation received
but also the dose rate per unit of time
or the dose rate in renkins per hour
this is the dosimeter
conveniently shaped to be worn on one
person at all times
it is able to measure the total
accumulated radiation exposure in renkin
the charger adjusts the dosimeter to a
zero reading prior to its use
with each separate exposure to radiation
building cumulatively on the dosimeter
gauge so that a reading of the total
dose is available at any given time
next the geiger counter this instrument
measures radiation in fractions of
wrenching per hour within or outside the
shelter
finally the survey meter able to measure
higher intensities of radiation that may
exist outside the shelter
for home shelters detection and
measuring instruments are available from
commercial sources
however most householders will rely
cheaply on their portable radios to
receive readings as they are taken by
civil defense monitoring teams
if there is a nuclear attack
and you survive the initial effects of
an explosion
you will have at least a half hour to
get to a public or home fallout shelter
therefore to be safe from radiation
sickness get into the best available
shelter as soon as possible once there
stay put
because each time you're exposed to
fallout radiation over a period of a few
days
the dosage continues to build until it
reaches dangerous quantity
if you're among those compelled to
travel through a fallout area on
essential errands there are certain
rules to follow
protect your body with boots or rubbers
gloves
headgear and outer clothing that can be
removed before you re-enter the shelter
on returning brush off the rest of your
clothing thoroughly as well as any parts
of your body that may have been exposed
to fallout
if sufficient water is available wash
your face and hands carefully
remember these are the dosages of
radiation as they affect human health
100 renkins little or no effects
300 renkins
sickness or death
600 renkins
death recovery from radiation sickness
is nothing new
patients who are treated by x-rays
routinely experience this sickness and
get over it
of course the dosages they receive are
carefully measured
just as in combating the virus of the
common cold
your general state of health will often
govern how quickly you can throw off the
effects of mild or moderate radiation
sickness
an emergency situation where there is no
doctor
always treat radiation sickness by
treating its symptoms
in fact these symptoms are often similar
to those produced by extreme anxiety or
emotional stress
so it's best not to try to determine
their cause
i repeat
do not try to diagnose
merely treat the symptoms just as you
would if they were the result of any
other type of illness
these are the symptoms of mild as well
as moderate radiation sickness
one or more of which may appear shortly
after exposure to fallout
fatigue
loss of appetite
nausea
vomiting
prostration
the treatment
is rest
for nausea you may give the patient any
of the commercial preparations that
settle an upset stomach
or one half teaspoon of baking soda in a
cup of water
tea and other hot liquids may be helpful
when a high fever is present apply cold
wet packs
aspirin also tends to reduce a fever
in severe radiation sickness along with
the early symptoms other symptoms may
appear a week or more after exposure
recovery is possible but it'll take
longer
the symptoms
are diarrhea
inflammation of mouth and throat
loss of hair
for treatment
control the diarrhea
and give aspirin and warm water gargles
people are naturally alarmed at the
thought of bodily changes that may
follow severe radiation sickness such as
loss of hair or sterility
these conditions are usually temporary
and will disappear with recovery
so i hope we've dispelled another
commonly held myth
you can get over radiation sickness just
as you get over many others
nevertheless
don't minimize the danger of fallout
remember its effects are cumulative
the only real protection against it is
to take shelter
now let's review some of the outstanding
facts we have learned in this brief
exploration of a vitally important
subject
fallout is composed of trillions of
particles of dust that are made
radioactive by residue from the nuclear
weapon during the aftermath of the
explosion
in a nuclear attack
depend on your local radio station to
tell you where fallout is taking place
you may be able to see some of the
fallout dust when it reaches the earth
but you cannot taste
smell or feel the radiation itself
the gamma rays given off by fallout are
able to injure or destroy the living
cells of our body if we are exposed long
enough
food or water in containers that prevent
contamination by fallout dust is
perfectly safe
radiation is harmful only to living
tissues
packaged foods that have been exposed to
fallout should be open carefully
by following proper procedures you can
eat such foods without danger to health
radiation can pass through most building
materials but its intensity is
diminished in proportion to the weight
and mass of the material or the
shielding
the intensity also decreases with
distance from the fallout
the radiation rate will decrease or
decay rapidly with time
it is most dangerous in the first few
days after explosion
thus the three basic factors that
protect you from fallout radiation are
time
distance and shielding
you should know the location of the
nearest public shelter in your community
inside it you will be at least 40 times
safer from fallout than you would be
outdoors
and it has been stocked with supplies to
sustain its occupants for up to two
weeks
if you're not within walking distance of
a public shelter you can provide a
satisfactory home shelter for your
family
radiation is invisible but we have
accurate instruments with which to
measure it in wrenching units
the dosimeter can be worn on the person
and measures the accumulated radiation
exposure the total dose at any given
time
the geiger counter measures radiation in
fractions of wrenchings per hour inside
or outside the shelter
the survey meter is used to measure the
higher intensities of radiation that may
be present outside the shelter assuming
that you have the protection of a good
shelter within a half hour after nuclear
attacks
you will probably have little or no
radiation sickness
if there are victims who appear to have
radiation sickness do not diagnose
treat the symptoms
perhaps the most important thing you
have learned is to see the danger in its
true perspective
make no mistake
nuclear attack would be a terrible
catastrophe
millions of our people would be killed
by the initial blast and heat
millions more would be threatened by
death from radioactive fallout
but that is a threat that can be
combated
can with knowledge
preparation
and curry
the face and concrete
[Music]
you